ils sont ici pour faire du business une
cinquantaine de dirigeants d'entreprises
yvelinois ont participé au lancement de
livre in business club une association
pour créer des relations entre les
sociétés du territoire il ya beaucoup de
d'entreprise yvelinoise aujourd'hui
qu'ils vont travailler avec ces grandes
entreprises du grand paris et c'est des
sous traitants on est là pour justement
les mettre en relation on voudrait
vraiment être un club aussi ouvert aux
femmes femmes dirigeantes
il y en a plein j'en connais plein et on
va aller les chercher on va y avons
adhéré au départ ça s'est fait sur une
passion commune qui sont les voitures et
les motos et en fait nous on est là pour
partager faire connaître nos produits
faire du business aussi évidemment est
ce que j'ai aimé que dans la proche de
ce club c'est le côté partage
convivialité
ce qui pour nous évidemment c'est de
participer à la croissance et donc de
trouver du nouveau pont du prospect qui
seront de nouveaux clients plus tard
pour devenir membre d'un club les chefs
d'entreprise sont sélectionnés ils
peuvent participer à des déjeuners
organisés chaque mois avec des
intervenants du monde sportif politique
ou économique
ils reviennent sur leur parcours à
l'image de gérard holtz ce journaliste
sportif parrain du club yvelinois ce
concept une idée du fondateur olivier
albert je pense que dans le sport c'est
un peu comme dans le business si vous
n'êtes pas honnête avec vous même et
avec les autres
si vous n'êtes pas loyal si vous n'êtes
pas au niveau bien vous avez des
déceptions ce qu'on perd et on peut
gagner donc il faut se remettre en cause
systématiquement il faut s'entraîner il
faut travailler et je pense que l'on
retrouve des vraies valeurs communes
entre le square le business l'idée c'est
d'échanger ses d'échangés ce que ce que
mon travail à la télévision mais 44 ans
oh tu
changer dans ma vie avec quelle idée
j'ai fait ça et qu'est ce que ça a pu
m'apporter voilà gérard holtz
interviendra lors du premier déjeuner le
5 février prochain au golf de la boulie
à versailles